no when welcome to this video I've got
my dick in a strange recently those men
like three white three black it's kind
of good weird okay that's good to buy
get Joan at the National master sit for
lock yeah can fairly normal English
opening position with the vertices six
let's do this making cookie five that's
sick why did I yeah and yes fifth all
about this for a moment at least yeah so
for the moment this is a nice piece on
day five I just hope that it you can
stay there for rabbit 95 already looks
pretty is pretty good him not so good I
take here you will go fo is
all right wanted to go t3 but this
doesn't hate this work actually it does
work let's do it add a bit of a
hallucination there and one quality of
my position is I'm better developed and
maybe this term amounts to something
maybe he probably came to a 95 again
that that move o rly let move had
irritated maybe 495 let's just take
stuff look you won first probably don't
really see a Quincy five maybe
[Music]
yeah okay I'm not going to just wait
what she does at then in near quincy
phone
[Music]
so tech the bishop yeah so here isn't
that something good here I can take b6 I
can take on you for some of this
position feels technically technically
vulnerable for black I don't see how ok
I just take the pawn it's not bad I just
I just felt like maybe I have something
better maybe plays Bishop g4 and that
looks a little bit a little bit more to
the point and so do i take on b6 yeah
should be one loses stuff
all we can do perform attacking covering
and b7 still hangs so probably here
but the [ __ ] route d 6 yeah okay he
wants to get counter play on the second
let's prevent this for the time being
threatening here and here it's a pretty
good rook ending those two pawns really
give black additional headaches I'm very
likely ending up with two pawns black
resigned that's only it is patty bad but
um it's a bit of an early resign I'm
winning another pawn so it should be a
winning position but still yeah I don't
know I don't really know why I think I'm
pretty unhappy that I allowed this d5 so
easily like a 4 a 4 is a it's not a move
that doesn't help much and if I am okay
I got some pressure there it's not it's
not totally terrible 494 didn't look at
this at all and it's probably better
than what i did here this looks a little
bit shaky the knight on d5 looks shaky a
move that always worried me was Knight
to g5 him maybe it isn't isn't that
dangerous a check it feels wrong somehow
engine doesn't see anything special if I
can do that I'm probably quite okay his
Bishop AI doesn't do all that much yet
and I'm very well-developed yeah
this is quite active and so on now I
don't know yeah Quincy finite see if I
wasn't move that I had on the right of
it he didn't look at this and I di think
I'm fine busting open everything I quit
before was winning ha what it is I did
what did i do then just bad this is a
loose piece to lose pieces queen before
oh ok I mean it's a nice position but I
mean it's nice anyway but that was a lot
stronger yeah yeah yeah I'm a lot better
and probably I'm winning time so kind of
surprised that here that he resigned um
and I'm winning both pawns and he gets
the a porn I think something like
something like this is probably going to
happen and here white this window I
would also get an F porn which is pretty
good can probably even play route be a
pawn to be seven and then March the
pawns ok guys thanks for watching